This video is made possible by
backblaze the unlimited backup solution.
You can get a 15 day free trial,
backblaze.com forward slash biographics.
Heinrich Muller was the man who ran the
most feared of all institutions in Nazi
Germany.
The Gestapo never developed Nazi.
He brought an unquestioning adherence,
do orders and do cold
calculating efficiency to
create an atmosphere of terror,
suspicion and darkness.
And then with the Nazi
regime crumbling around him,
you simply disappeared.
What did he and this week's bond graphics,
we take a look at the life and the
disappearance of Heinrich Muller.
I'd recommended was born to
Catholic parents in Munich,
Germany on April the 28th,
1900.
He had a middle class upbringing with
his father serving as a rural police
officer.
I'm rick experienced a primary school
level education before going on to train
as an apprentice mechanic in the exciting
new field of aircraft engineering.
Seventeen year olds Miller join
the German army in June 19,
17 and in the 17 months that were to
remain if the first world war one both
promotion and to claim in April 19,
18,
he was assigned to the flag.
I was building up to 287 where he flew
planes in an artillery spotting unit in
August,
19,
18.
Louis was promoted to NCO.
He was awarded the Iron Cross first
and second class while serving on the
western front after sustaining a
leg injury in a plane accident.
He was awarded the retired Bavarians
badge is mental whole during his short
period of service.
Also included the Bavarian military
cross second class with swords.
It was quite an accomplishment
for an 18 year old
after leaving the German army,
Miller founds employment as a junior
assistant for the Munich police force.
After a period of time,
he passed his entrance exam to
become a police officer by now.
He had reached his full height at five
foot seven inches tall and he had a
strong athletic builds and Willa kept
his dark brown hair cropped very short on
the sides.
He had a small mouth and
was rarely seemed to smile.
While his extremely intense day,
I would often a nerve
those in his company.
The first world war injury voted ended.
His war,
Korea caused him to walk
with a constant level.
Will have married a girl named Sophie
Dictionary in Nineteen Twenty Four.
Sophie's father was the publisher
of a right wing newspaper room,
was opposed to the new National Socialist
Party and its leader at of Hitler.
Mila was to stick to his
faith throughout his career,
despite the Nazi parties antipathy
towards the church three years into the
marriage,
his son reinhard was born.
The marriage was to last for some
30 years with the second child,
girl named Elizabeth.
Born on September the ninth,
1936.
The child was said to be not quite right,
which led to a strain in the marriage.
Subsequently engaged in an affair
with his private secretary,
Barbara Hellmouth and the marriage.
It was essentially over
over a 10 year period,
mother rose in the ranks to become
police secretary in 1929 by now.
He was serving in the section
six of the Bavarian state police.
This unit was mainly concerned with
seeking out and keeping a lid on communist
activity in and around Munich.
By the time he had reached the age of 30,
Mila had to become a rabid anticommunist.
Thanks.
In part to his having been a witness
to communist hostage murders during the
Bavarian state republic during the
German revolution of 1918 to 1919,
his energetic performance of his duties
and willingness to follow orders without
question earmarked him as a man with
a future in the new Germany during his
service with the Bavarian state police
mother ran in circles that included Nazi
leaders,
Reinhardt,
Heidrick,
and Heinrich Himmler.
However,
this time mullah no doubt
under the influence of his
father in law was decidedly
anti Nazi when the Nazis overthrew the
Bavarian government on March the ninth,
19,
33.
Well,
it was in favor of picking up arms
to actively resist hitless forces
with the barrier and its police force
under the control of the Nazis will
approved to be a valuable
asset for the new regime.
Has Knowledge of communist activities,
but in high demands and t advanced in
rank to become a criminal investigator.
In November of 1933,
he was a bit of a workaholic and exhibited
a high degree of self discipline and
ruthlessness.
His early experiences in the army had
instilled in him they military compliance
to orders that was highly
appreciated by the Nazi leaders,
is natural antipathy towards the Nazi
party capital from becoming a member until
he was compelled to do so in 1930,
nine years earlier,
referred to Hitler as an immigrant
unemployed house painter.
As a result of his
auntie nancy sentiments.
He was kept under constant surveillance
by the party in 1937 report referred to
him as ruthless and continually tries
to demonstrate his efficiency but claims
all the glory for himself.
However,
the truth of the Iraqi security
office Reinhardt Heidrick,
so a lack of blind
devotion to the Nazi party.
There's an asset he was increasingly
impressed by Mala having kept a close eye
on his police career in mullet.
He saw a man who was completely
focused on the minute detail of his job
description without a concern
for the bigger picture.
From 1933 onward,
began doing work for the Nazi party
under the direction of Heidrick.
He would be given accounts and reports
detailing Nazi atrocities and turns them
into dry administrative reports.
In 1934,
he joined the secret service or the SS
in 1933 when Hitler became chancellor of
Germany,
Hermann goring,
Hitler's second in command became
interior minister of Russia.
This button in commands of the
largest police force in Germany.
Guerin created the Gestapo by amalgamating
the various branches of the Prussian
police forces.
The name was an
abbreviation of gooey Hina,
starts Palencia or secret police.
On April the 20th,
19,
34 SS leader,
Heinrich Himmler became
head of the Gestapo.
On that same day,
Hitler appointed him chief of police for
all states apart from Prussia two days
days up him that handed the leadership
of the Gestapo to Reinhardt Heidrick,
who still retained his
position as head of the SS.
On June the 17th,
1936 hipper appointed him as
chief of old German police,
including those in Prussia.
This movie gave him low operational
control over all of Germany's detective
forces.
The Gestapo had now become a national
agency as opposed to simply a Prussian
state agency.
Endless even created the criminal
police or criminal police,
merging it with the Gestapo to
form the CFO or secret police,
heidrick retains control,
making Heinrich Muller and his
operational chief in the wake of Hipaa.
Nineteen 38 onslaughts of Austria.
Mila was also made inspector of
security police for Australia.
It was Miller who gave the orders that
resulted in the arrest of up to 30,000
Jews on the night of November
the ninth to the 10th,
1938,
a date that history remembers as the
Kristallnacht or the night of broken glass
as a subordinate of Heidrick.
He also did most of the administrative
work in preparing for the immigration of
all Jews from Europe under the auspices
of the central office for Jewish
emigration.
Three years later on September the 27th,
19,
39,
the security and police agencies all
over the country were brought together to
form the right name,
security office or R,
m s a,
which was under the control of Heidrick.
The Gestapo was now officially
department for of the RMS RMSC,
heinrich muller.
He was named the Gestapo chief will
have finally joined the Nazi party in
November of 1939 after being
pressured to do you say by Heidrick.
From this time onward,
he became known as Gestapo Miller to
differentiate him from another Nazi
official who bowl the same name.
On August the 11th,
19,
39.
Adult fitness stated the following to
the League of Nations High Commissioner.
If that is the slightest provocation,
I will shatter Poland without warning and
just so many pieces that there will be
nothing left to pick up.
What he needed.
Next was that provocation which will
allow him to unleashes war machine and set
the world on the road to war to create it.
He turned to the Gestapo as a result,
heidrick and works together to bring
about the Polish provocation that Hitler
had warned about.
The plot to create the reuse of a
Polish propagation was called Operation
Tannenberg.
They decided to create a series of fake
border attacks in which Germans living
on the Polish border would be the
victims of attacks by Polish insurgents
literate.
Heidrick settled on the border
area near the town of Grievance.
Yeah.
Well,
situated,
isolated German outposts that would
make logical targets for attack.
It was decided that fake attacks
would be made on a forestry station,
a customs house,
and a radio station.
SS soldiers were recruited into the scheme
and dressed as petition surgeons and
as Polish army personnel.
More SS troops were then
clad in German army uniforms.
A last minute touched to the plan was
that some of the polls would be killed in
the attack so that their bodies
can be presented to the welds.
Media concentration camp
inmates were brought into play.
The part of these poles who were about
to be put to death operation Tannenberg
was stationed to go into action
at 4:30 AM on August the 26th.
Then we're to be three successive
code words and the various units.
Where do you cross the border?
Once the last code word was issued after
the release of the second code word,
some units became confused and
headed for the border prematurely,
but then he changed his mind.
The attack would be delayed.
Mental motorbikes were sent out to
bring back the attacking fake polls.
Hitler held back because
of British guarantees.
Deponent,
after consultation with Heidrick and Mila,
it was decided that the
plan would be revised.
It was also felt that a real Polish
insurgent would be needed so that he could
be put to death and paraded
to the world's newspapers,
Melissa,
through his files and came up with
the name of Franz [inaudible],
who was a prominent Polish
sympathizer on August the 30th,
Melissa,
and his men to pick up on the Iraq.
The attacks were carried out
on the evening of August,
the 31st starting at 8:00 PM.
A drug,
friends,
honey alk was dragged out and propped
up against the radio station entrance.
It was then shot in the head.
Photos were taken and delivered
back to mother and Heidrick,
but they were deemed as not being good
enough to be used for media propaganda
purposes.
Still,
the fake attacks serve that purpose.
The following day,
September the first 19,
39 adult Hitler referred to
them as justification for
his attack on the Poland.
Two days later,
Britain and France declared war on
Germany and the Second World War was
underway.
Heinrich Muller was now in charge of
the most ruthless arm of the Nazi party.
His brief was to stamp out all manner of
oppression to the regime he immediately
set about in his methodically
efficient manner,
so you create an instrument
of state sponsored terror.
The Gestapo were given the job of
investigating every act of treason,
espionage,
and sabotage perpetrated against the
state law that had been passed in 1936,
gave them free reign to
operate without any restraints.
This law gave the organization
exemption from any responsibility to the
administrative courts so long as the
Gestapo were acting in harmony with the
will of the Nazi leadership than
they weren't acting lawfully.
The aspects of the Gestapo is activities
that was most open to abuse was called
the soft,
which translates to protective custody.
It gave them the authority to imprison
anyone without having gone through any
court proceedings.
As a result,
thousands of people were beaten
mercilessly with many of them simply
disappearing.
This gave the Gestapo a fearsome
reputation throughout the labs.
Fear in fact became the
gestapos greatest weapon.
Mila was a highly skilled
interrogated himself.
He would draw interrogations out for
hours on end is making full use of his
incredible memory to trip up his subjects.
We only have one surviving accounts
of an interrogation conducted by Moda,
his opening words to his subjects,
a British officer where you are
in the hands of the Gestapo.
Don't imagine that we shall show you the
slightest consideration with the onset
of war.
The Gestapo numbers web
bolstered substantially by 1942.
Mother was in charge of around
46,000 offices as German conquest.
It's mounted the operations of the
Gestapo extended to occupied territories.
Its duties were extended to
putting down resistance movements.
To do this effectively with only 46,000
men will have cultivated the perception
among the population that the
state was constantly watching,
that nobody was safe.
The miss sight of like a staff,
a unit would instill terror in people.
The general feeling was that if you
did anything against the Nazi stage,
the Gestapo,
they would eventually track you down and
then your life simply wouldn't be worth
living.
In order to cultivate the fear that
was needed to control the people,
I was happy to leak the details of the
sorts of torture that his underlings were
inflicting upon those taken into custody.
The more gruesome the story,
the better.
He also organized for the occasional show
trials to be held in public where the
People's court would vehemently denounced,
convict,
and then condemn a prisoner
to the firing squad.
Mother's favorite people's got judge
was the notorious redlands fries.
They're the custodian,
had offices at every concentration camp.
Personnel from the Gestapo were also used
to make up the Einsatzgruppen or death
squad.
Suit carried out mass killings.
The Gestapo were largely responsible
for putting into action hitless plan for
the elimination of the
Jewish people from Europe.
To accomplish this,
the office of resettlement native to
become the office of Jewish affairs was
created.
It was headed by adult Eichmann who
was Miller's immediate subordinate.
Together the two men implemented a mass,
deportation and exterminations that Nazi
concentration camps throughout occupied
Europe.
On march the second 19,
44 signs the infamous bullets decree which
ordered that escaped allied prisoners
were to be transported to the meth
house in Goossen concentration camp and
summarily executed.
This was in direct contravention of the
Geneva Convention in the wake of the
July,
the 20th,
1944 plot to kill Hitler.
It was Miller who authorized the use of
torture to interrogate those involved in
fact his zeal in the aftermath of the
attack and in the knight's cross to the
war service with swords
under his oversight,
more than 7,000 people were arrested
with 4,980 either committing suicide or
being executed.
Mullins duties included overseeing counter
espionage operations between 1942 and
1945.
These were focused on the Soviet Union.
Much success was achieved in feeding
false information to the Russians and even
in turning a number of Soviet agents.
Well,
it may have never been
a dyed in the wool Nazi,
but he believed the German
victory was inevitable.
Even in the last days.
He thought that a final German victory
in the den could turn the tide of the war
as the Russians and the Americans
closed in on Berlin in April of 1945.
Below was among those secrets
in the underground bunker
that was now home to the
rep in the final days to discover that
Hermann goring had secretly undertaken
peace negotiation with the allies
enraged the Phyrra ordered Miller to
interrogate Waffen ss
general an about what?
A new of gatherings,
underhanded dealings.
This interrogation,
his last official duty resulted in the
execution of felon on April the 30th
that'll fella and his wife Eva Braun,
committed suicide the next day.
May.
The first molar was quoted by Hitler's
personal pilot is saying we know are some
methods exactly.
I haven't the faintest intention of
being taken prisoner by the Russians that
evening have disappeared from the bunker.
Just happened to.
It remains one of the great
mysteries of the Nazi era.
For almost 70 years,
he remains the most senior Nazi
official to remain unaccounted.
Yeah.
On June the 18th,
1945,
the allied counter intelligence war rim
released a statement that concluded that
it seems clear from most reports that
molo remained in Berlin after the collapse
over the next few weeks,
several high ranking Gestapo
officers were arrested,
but the man at the head of the terror
organization was nowhere to be found with
Heinrich Muller being
a common German name.
The ally has found many molars
but never the right one.
This led to many false alerts
and frustrating dead ends,
so the United States counter intelligence
services were determined to keep
tracking down.
There were reports that he had taken on
the name of Schwartz or Schwartzer and
traveled south in the company
of a fellow Gestapo officer,
but this ended up as yet another dead end.
By the mid 19 forties,
the general consensus was
that Heinrich Muller had died.
The dramatic may 19,
60 capture of adults come in by.
The Israelis reawakened interest in
the search for the Nazis in general and
Heinrich Muller in particular.
I commit himself,
added to the interest by stating at his
trial that he was of the opinion that
Mona was still alive in July 19,
60.
The West German police were brought in
to open an into motos whereabouts it was
suspected that wherever he was little
I was corresponding with his family,
former secretary or mistress.
All of the things people were
therefore put under surveillance.
The West Germans developed
three major leads in the case,
each one confirming the belief that
he had met his end in Berlin in 1945.
This eventually led to the exclamation
of a grave in a cemetery in West Berlin
despite the fact that the
gravestone read our loving father,
Heinrich Mila born April the 28th,
1900,
died in Berlin,
may 19,
45.
The grave did not contain Mila's body.
The American CIA began to such familiar.
It's around the same time as
this west German investigation.
It was prompted by the defection of a
Polish intelligence officer who reveals
information about a
handful of escaped Nazis,
including the defects are informed,
the CIA that Miller had been taken into
custody by the Soviets and was working
in Moscow.
In counter intelligence,
the CIA attempted to corroborate the
Polish defect is inflammation with limited
success throughout the remainder of the
19 sixties that were various reports of
my love living in South American
countries such as Argentina or Chile.
Still no concrete needs emerge though.
Finally,
in 2013,
it appeared that conclusive evidence
that emerged proving that Heinrich Muller
did in fact,
Diane Berlin in 1945 research on the part
of the memorial for German resistance
concluded that he was buried in a mass
grave with around 2,400 other people in
Berlin.
The conclusion is based on a report of a
barrier commander which detailed to the
discovery of the body complete with Mona's
military identification papers in his
pocket,
so it would appear that the most
elusive of the Nazi hierarchy,
it's not simply the new of after role.
Just before we finished the video today,
I do want to say a particularly
big thank you to today's sponsor,
backblaze.
Now video is like this.
I personally feel that important,
but because of the way youtube works,
it's hard for them to be made because
of advertising restrictions on youtube
that you're probably familiar with.
If you're a regular watcher of well,
anything on youtube now,
this sponsor,
they also happen to
provide an amazing service,
so please do support them and support
us by checking out this great deal,
backblaze that a backup solution,
and it really is simply the best way to
backup any files that you have on your
computer.
As a video creator that I work with a
lot of data and I need that all to be
security backs up,
which I do with baclays.
In fact,
as I sit here,
my computer is over there singing
my files with backblaze servers,
security,
of course they use military
grade encryption now.
I've used backblaze for years.
They provide unlimited personal storage
for a low monthly fee and better yet
it's totally hands off.
When I put a file on my computer or save
a new document or do anything like that
back lace,
automatically it gets to
a mirroring that fall,
that video with their service.
Then if I ever have a computer failure
or my data gets destroyed somehow touch
wood,
I can just download it from backblaze
or more likely just to let them ship me
out a hard disk for a refundable
feet with all my files on it,
but if you're not sure this is for you,
then you can find out if it's for you
with the 15 day free trial that our users
get just for watching biographics.
You can find a link to that
in the description below.
Like I say,
sponsors on this type of video.
It's super important and I'd
love it if you tried the mouse.
Just go to backblaze.com
forward slash biographics.
Again,
as I said,
there's a link in the description below.
Give this video a like if you liked it,
subscribe for more stuff twice a week,
and as always,
thank you for watching.